in the game of Thrones TV show Stannis
Baratheon dies with all the pathos and
excitement of damp fart after a
storyline four seasons long he rolls
over and dies and it's the Starks who
defeat the Bolton's and retake the north
but in the book series northern politics
is an intricate web of alliances
rivalries secrets and lies while an
apocalyptic winter rises and through the
ice
Stannis marches on Winterfell with a
plan to defeat the Bolton's the Bolton's
are holed up in Winterfell with an army
of frays and Northman most of whom
secretly hate the Bolton's Wyman
Manderly plots betrayal Barbary Dustin
stalks the crypts and Theon is
traumatized by Ramsay who calls Theon
reek Ramsay doesn't marry Sansa he
marries a girl called Jane who the
Bolton's say is I a stark up on the wall
Jon Snow tries to make peace between the
Nights Watch and the wildlings along
with Melisandre and Stannis's family
John hears that his beloved sister aya
married Ramsay so he and Melisandre send
the wildling king of mance rayder
to rescue her Melisandre pretended to
burn man spurt that was an illusion and
he's actually still alive
so mance and six wildling women
infiltrate Winterfell and with their
help Jane and Theon escape to Stannis
Stannis and his army prepare to fight
the Bolton's but at the end of the
latest book Jon gets a mysterious letter
from Ramsay called the pink letter it
says that Stannis is dead and mance is
captured Ramsay says he wants his bride
back and once reek back he demands
Stannis's family and some wildlings keep
them from me he says and I will cut out
your bastards heart and eat it so John
is shook and he declares that he'll
leave the Nights Watch and ride south to
fight Ramsay so then the watch stabs Jon
to death the pink letter changes
everything in the
but fans suspect that it's a trick or a
fake tormund warns us that the letter
might be full of lies
so is Stannis really dead was this
letter even written by Ramsay what's
happening at Winterfell in the game of
Thrones books it's hard to believe that
Stannis is dead because his story is not
over yet the whole fifth book builds up
to his battle for Winterfell and author
George Martin said we'll see the battle
in the next book so why would Stannis
suddenly die off-screen in this letter
why spoil the climax of his story
Stannis is in a bad situation his army
is snowbound and starving in a village
near Winterfell and the Bolton's sent
the phrase out to attack him but Stannis
is confident he says let them come and
says he'll tone the ground to his
advantage what does he mean at the start
of the book it says that Stannis once
went to an island with a lighthouse he
learned that sometimes people would turn
off the lighthouse and create a false
light somewhere else to lure ships into
danger and now it just so happens that
Stannis's camp has a watch tower with a
beacon fire that burns day and night and
next to the camp are some frozen lakes
his men fished the lakes by cutting
holes in the ice and ice becomes so
dangerous that some men fall through
into the water so if Stannis puts out
the fire on his watchtower and he lights
a false beacon on the frozen lake he
could lure the Freys onto the dangerous
ice and attack them there maybe break
the ice with catapults so the Freys fall
through and drown that must be what
Stannis means by toning the ground to
his advantage
so the hints are all there it seems
almost certain that Stannis will use a
false fire on the lakes to defeat the
phrase you can read more about this
theory in the articles below but if
Stannis wins this battle why does the
pink letter say Stannis is dead
well last time we see him Stannis
specifically says you may hear that I am
dead
so some fans think he's planning to fake
his own death because as well as the
phrase of the manderlys are coming for
Stannis
but the manderlys are coming separately
from the phrase because they've been
fighting at one point Wyman serves meat
pies made out of phrase Wyman is
planning to betray the Bolton's and he
made a secret deal to support Stannis so
instead of fighting each other maybe
Stannis and the man delese will work
together and will trick the Bolton's
into thinking that Stannis is dead
so after Stannis beats the phrase wyman
could go back to Winterfell and tell the
Bolton's that Stannis was defeated as
proof Manderley could have Stannis's
sword Lightbringer which Ramsay says he
has in the pink letter but secretly
Stannis would be still alive
he could use the low visibility in the
snowstorm to sneak up for an attack on
Winterfell Ramsay would be totally
unprepared thinking Stannis is dead he'd
just be angry that John sent mance to
steal his bride that's why Ramsay
threatens John in the letter and demands
Jane and Theon who would likely seek
refuge with John wall so this is a
pretty likely explanation of the pink
letter Ramsay wrote the letter thinking
that Stannis is dead though Stannis is
actually still alive but there are other
theories the letter seems to fit
Ramsay's personality it's angry and
cruel Ramsay repeatedly calls Jon
bastard because Ramsay is insecure about
being a bastard himself Ramsay is also
cunning and manipulative he might be
trying to provoke Jon into doing
something stupid which he does but some
details of the letter seem off in the
book we see three threatening letters
from Ramsay Asha Greyjoy gets a letter
John gets a letter and then John gets
the pink letter and these letters are
described in detail Ash's letter is
tightly rolled and sealed with a button
of hard pink wax it's written in blood
that looks like brown ink the
handwriting is huge and spiky it's
signed by Ramsay and by his allies lady
dust and
one for rizz Wells and one Amba the
second letter to John is described in
almost exactly the same way tightly
rolled and sealed with a button of hard
pink wax blood brown ink huge spiky hand
signed by ramsey Dustin Cohen for rizz
Wells and one amber it's all super
specific and consistent so it's weird
that the pink letter is described
differently it's got a smear of pink wax
but there's no mention of brown ink or
of a huge spiky hand it's signed by
ramsey but not by anyone else so why is
the pink letter different some of the
content of the letter is also suspicious
like it makes sense that Ramsay wants
his bride Jane and his reek Theon and it
makes sense that he wants Stannis's
family as political prisoners but Ramsay
also says he wants the wildling princess
Val and her baby nephew why would he
want these wildlings
how does Ramsay even know that vowels
baby nephew exists if Ramsay really did
capture mance he could have interrogated
him to learn these details but it's not
clear why he would care it's surprising
how much of this letter is focused on
mance and the wildlings is he just
really angry at mance for rescuing Jane
the letter refers to the Nights Watch as
black crows a term that's almost only
used by wildlings the letter talks about
heads on walls and threatens to cut out
John's heart when Ramsay's favorite kind
of execution is flying but there is
another character who once threatened to
cut out John's heart a wildling who
would care about Val and the baby the
only character mentioned by name in this
letter mance rayder the wildling king
may be the reason why the pink letter is
different to Ramsay's other letters and
the reason why it's so focused on the
wildlings is that Ramsay didn't write it
mance did in the books Mance Rayder is a
maverick charismatic leader who uses
cunning and deception to manipulate
people right at the start of book 1 when
King Robert visits Winterfell mance is
actually at the
feast he climbs the wall and comes in
disguise to spy in book three manse
claims that he has the Horn of winter
magic horn with the power to destroy the
wall but it turns out that man's lied to
manipulate John mance has history with
John the first time they met mance
warned John not to play tricks with him
but John ends up betraying mance by
leaving the wildlings
so maybe mance pulls a trick on John by
writing the pink letter mance has
recently used a lot of the same language
that's in the pink letter he calls
Melisandre a red witch calls John
bastard and calls the Nights Watch crows
he says that mance was burned for all
the world to see and the pink letter
says mance is in a cage for all the
north to see it's probably possible for
Mane's to fake a letter from Ramsay when
mance infiltrates Winterfell he pretends
to be a singer called Abel and he hangs
around the Bolton's so he might have
learned enough about Ramsay's character
to impersonate him in a letter
man speaks with Theon so he could have
learned about Ramsay's relationship with
reek and with Jane and he maybe could
have stolen some pink wax and a raven to
send a letter he would have been in a
rush so maybe that's why the letter is
sealed with a smear of wax the difficult
question is why mance would ride a
letter like even if mance could predict
that the letter would make Jon ride
south with some wildlings how does that
help manse manse doesn't want the
wildlings to fight in Stannis's war
mount says his people have bled enough
maybe manse wants help for him to escape
Winterfell
but if mance wants help there's got to
be a better way to ask for it than to
impersonate Ramsay to provoke Jon into
rallying wildlings it's a ridiculously
convoluted plan why would mance ask for
reek and why ask for Val and the baby
it's his baby and asking for them could
only put them in danger right mance does
seem to have some secret plan in
Winterfell he investigates the
Winterfell crypts and the name Abel is
an anagram of bale allege
a wildling said to have snuck into
Winterfell and stolen a stark girl just
like man sneaks into Winterfell to
rescue is stock bail is said to have
hidden in the Winterfell crypts
so maybe mance plans to hide in the
crypts
maybe mance is searching for the real
Horn of winter in the crypts he searched
for the horn in graves beyond the wall
maybe now he's searching for it in stark
graves
so mance is up to something and there
are some weird connections between mance
and a letter but it's hard to see why
mance would write the letter another
theory is that Stannis wrote the pink
letter because in his last chapter
Stannis is facing a battle that he might
not win even if he beats the phrase with
a bacon and the lake's there are still
thousands of Bolton's in one of the
strongest castles in Westeros Stannis's
army might not be enough so maybe he
wants the help of John and the wildlings
Stannis has asked for Jon's support
before but John said his sworn to the
Nights Watch asking directly doesn't
work but if Stannis fakes a letter from
Ramsay threatening John and his sister
and threatening the wildling King mance
that could motivate John and the
wildlings to ride south and help Stannis
win his war this could also fit with
Stannis's plan to make John Lord of
Winterfell if he leaves the watch he
might as well take up Stannis's offer
and thing is Stannis just captured a
Bolton maester who would know Ramsay's
riding style and might have the wax and
raven to send the pink letter Stannis
also captured Theon who could tell him
about mance and reek and the other
details in the letter so it seems
possible for Stannis to write the pink
letter and unlike mance Stannis has a
clear motive but the biggest problem
with this is that Stannis's army is
starving it's so bad that they're
starting to eat their own dead
so Stannis doesn't have time to wait
around for John and an army to travel
down from the wall that distance would
take weeks or months to cover in winter
by which time Stannis and his army would
be dead it might work if Stannis sent
the letter earlier but earlier he didn't
have thin
and the Meister so he wouldn't know to
include the details about manse and reek
and the stuff on the letter and also
faking a letter just isn't Stannis's
style like it's one thing to pull off a
military maneuver with a false bacon but
faking the pink letter means
impersonating ramsey and emotionally
manipulating John Stannis is terrible
with emotions he's bad with people and
psychologically manipulating John with a
fake letter just isn't the sort of thing
that he'd do the further if the real
purpose of the pink letter is to
motivate John to come south you'd think
it a talk more about Arya and bless
about hostages and maths
why would Stannis demand reak when
Stannis already has reek and John
doesn't know what a reek is Stannis
probably didn't write the pink letter
some fans argue that Melisandre wrote
the letter
Melisandre does have some secret schemes
going on she faked manses death and
sending him to Winterfell was her idea
John suspects that Mel has some secret
other plan with mance so some fans think
that Mansur Melisandre wrote the letter
together though the motive is still
unclear Melisandre has visions of the
future in her fires and she actually
predicts the arrival of the pink letter
before it comes so maybe she also knew
what would happen after the pink letter
came that John would be stabbed to death
but then be resurrected by Mel's magic
and ultimately would go on to help save
the world
maybe Mel finally realized that Stannis
isn't the chosen one John is so she
could have written the pink letter to
get John killed to fulfill his destiny
but Melisandre repeatedly warns John not
to get stabbed and last we saw she still
thinks Stannis is the chosen one so
there's no real evidence for Melisandre
writing the pink letter
another possibility is Barbary Dustin
she's a new character in book 5 and
she's mysterious openly she supports the
Bolton's but she hates Ramsay because
Ramsay murdered her
for you Barbary asks Theon to show her
the Winterfell crypts around the same
time that mance asks about the crypts so
some fans think that mance and Barberie
might be working together
there are also hints of barberry working
with Wyman Manderly and his conspiracy
like maybe they wrote the pink letter to
lure John south so that he can be king
in the north
go watch our Grand Northern conspiracy
video so there's a lot of intrigue and
mystery happening in the north it seems
like every second character has some
secret plot or identity even this bloody
baby is actually secretly a different
baby because Jon swapped him out with
Keeley's baby but most of this stuff is
probably unrelated to the pink letter
the pink letter is memorable because
it's the last thing that happens before
Jon dies and it's been nine years since
that book came out so fans have had a
lot of time to overthink it and come up
with crazy theories about who wrote the
letter the theories are fun but based on
the texts they makes the most sense for
Ramsay to write the letter because the
letter doesn't just have the plot
purpose of provoking Jon and getting him
stabbed it has an emotional purpose by
forcing Jon to choose between family and
duty and setting up Ramsay as a hated
enemy if it turns out that the pink
letter was a fake for some obscure
subplot that could take away from the
emotional weight of this gut punch at
the end of the book and there still can
be a cool twist to the pink letter that
Stannis isn't really dead because there
actually are strong hints in the text
that Stannis will beat the phrase but
we'll only know the truth when the next
book comes out until then all of God is
theories if you want to know more about
the mysteries of Game of Thrones you've
got to check out the books as well as
the main series there's the world book
and fire and blood and the dunk and egg
stories and you can get any of these on
audiobook for free right now by signing
up for a trial with audible members get
an audiobook each month and if you
cancel you keep the audiobooks you can
listen in the car or the gym or while
you wait for winter to come sign up at
audible.com slash a s
thanks for watching please like and
subscribe and comment below who you
think wrote the pink letter
thanks to patrons a Yubel army gen Casey
Kenner Teresa Molly Marie Rose and tybor
Cheers
you